today the covert inquiry has threatened
legal action after some communication
from Boris Johnson WhatsApp messages and
Diaries were withheld a lot of evidence
has been handed over to the covid
inquiry but the criticism from the head
of the inquiry is that quite a lot of
information was redacted well we've just
had a reply from the cabinet office a
spokesperson for the cabinet office
reacting to this it says we are fully
committed to our obligations to the
covert inquiry as such the cabinet
office alone has already provided
upwards of 55 000 documents 24 personal
witness statements eight corporate
statements and extensive time and effort
has gone into assisting the inquiry
fulsomely over the last 11 months we
will continue to provide all relevant
material to the inquiry in line with the
law ahead of proceedings getting
underway so that's the cabinet office's
response to the covert inquiry
threatening legal action over
information they believe has been
withheld